sommes en direct avec fouad zmokhol il
est président du rassemblement des
dirigeants et chefs d'entreprise
libanais dans le monde
bonsoir et merci d'être en direct avec
nous que révèle cette affaire selon vous
je précise que concernant donc cette
vidéo publiée par le porte-parole en
question on l'a dit certains disent
qu'il a été intimidé chose qu'il dément
quel est votre regard sur cette affaire
votez tout d'abord je ne peux cacher mon
indignation mat au fond de tristesse qui
est ressenti par tous les libanais au
liban et dans le monde pour ce qu'on
croyait vraiment un cauchemar qui était
il faisait partie peut-être de
l'histoire et revoir nos plus tristes
souvenirs de la guerre devenir réalité
en face de nous sur un terrain
extrêmement minet sur détention est
vraiment à l'ombre d'une des plus
grandes crises économique sociale
politique et sécuritaire aujourd'hui il
n'y a aucun doute que je vais dire que
les conséquences ou même les causes de
ses actes et ses mouvements de foule de
l'intimidation ou autres sont vraiment
relié directement à un procès à un
tribunal il faut pas oublier d'une des
plus grandes explosions du monde et à
vrai dire aujourd'hui ce n'est ni notre
rôle des procureurs ni avocat les mêmes
juges pour décider mais ce n'est pas un
hasard finalement que certains partis
politiques
dès qu'ils sont questionnés on va même
pas dire pointé du doigt et ce n'est pas
la première fois on avait ça durant les
dernières quinze ou vingt années m'a
finalement tout est bon pour empêcher
vraiment un tribunal claire avoir des
vraies réponses au liban donc toutes
sortes de pressions sont fait des
pressions de la rue dépression
sécuritaire des pressions de certaines
personnes pour évidemment empêché
d'avoir vraiment un tribunal une
investigation claire transparente et des
résultats on a connu ça sur les derniers
attentats et autres donc à notre avis
finalement on peut pas savoir ce qui
s'est vraiment passé mais finalement je
pense que tous les libanais les familles
des victimes et tous les libanais dans
le monde va vraiment savoir ce qui s'est
passé est à dire une des plus grandes
explosions aujourd'hui aucune personne
coupé pour vous poser cette question en
quoi les vrais mots tête en tant que
porte parole
je le rappelle d'un collectif proches
des victimes de l'explosion au port de
beyrouth en quoi aurait-il intérêt à ce
que le juge chargé de cette enquête se
récuse
regardez finalement il faut faire
attention qu'on a beaucoup de partis
aujourd'hui qu'ils veulent paraître que
ce que ce que ce juge vous bien que
cette investigation est politisée
aujourd'hui finalement ce juge c'est
bien son travail c'est son travail de
questionner de demander finalement il
n'y a pas de point cacher il ya quand
même des faits très clair il ya 2500 ou
2700 tonnes de nitrates qui sont rentrés
sur un port de beyrouth qui est sous
contrôle de l'état ses 2700 tonnes il
n'en restait que 500 ou 600 qui ont
explosé donc il ya plus que 2000 ou de
1200 tonnes qui sont sortis de ce port
de façon évidemment au noir et une
grande partie où la dernière partie qui
a explosé et qui a détruit la capitale
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est encore
prématuré de dire si ce monsieur subi
des pressions ou pas mais en tant que
spectateur on peut dire que si on suit
un peu toutes les interviews télévisées
de ce monsieur les familles des liquides
c'est lé plus grand fervent partisan il
n'y a que quelques heures ou quelques
jours encore ce monsieur mettez les
accusations des points d'interrogation
un peu sur toute la classe politique
donc ce retournement de situation
soudain quand même mais beaucoup de
questions mais honnêtement je pense
qu'il faut il faudrait pas cool et on
vire dans des changements de situation
c'est extrêmement clair qu'on a quand
même un pouvoir judiciaire
on est pour l'indépendance du pouvoir
judiciaire on est injuste qui a été
nommé par le même état et quel hasard
que ce même état aujourd'hui veut le
destituer ce juge qui fait son travail
finalement il a défait il travaille de
façon très claire et transparente et
tout ce qu'on demande en tant que peuple
libanais en temps d'économie c'est
d'avoir certaines réponses donc
aujourd'hui c'est un peu claires et ce
n'est pas un hasard que ces mouvements
de foule ces coups de feu des morts des
intimidations qui est tout un changement
une fois que le juge a essayé de faire
certains appels je dois rappeler wall
facebook comment comment est-ce que vous
expliquer cette montée des tensions
autour du juge bitar et de cette enquête
je vous répète ma question comment vous
expliquer cette montée des tensions
autour du juge bitar et madame c'est
cette montée de tension on l'a on l'a
reçu vue de la même façon après
l'assassinât du premier ministre avery
on l'a vu aussi après la cie du cycle
d'assassinât qui a suivi 2005 sur des
parlementaires sur des ministres et
autres donc il faut dire qu on a aussi
des parties au liban qui veulent
appliquer leur propre loi à une fois que
la loi légal est appliquée vers eux bien
évidemment tout change tournure donc il
est très clair que certaines personnes
certains protagonistes veulent cacher la
vérité ou veulent cacher la réalité et
ne croit qu'à leurs propres lois il faut
bien dire et je redis si on veut
restructurer le pays on est obligé
d'avoir un état de droit on est obligé
de respecter quand même état judiciaire
et finalement s'il ya erreur ou pas le
sucre est de faire de revoir mais
aujourd'hui la pression de la rue les
intimidations sur certaines personnes
dont vont faire qu'augmenter les
soupçons sur les personnes qui veulent
réellement cacher ce qui s'est passé sur
le merci beaucoup au foie de ce mot
colle pour toutes ces précisions je
rappelle que vous êtes président du
rassemblement des dirigeants et chefs
d'entreprise libanais dans le monde
merci à vous